ah summer time as the Griswolds would
tell you it's the best time for weekend
getaways and full week family vacations
but before you pack those bags let's
review what the movies teach us about
those classic vacay destinations
the beach it's the perfect place to get
a tan catch some waves and get eaten by
a shark piranhas another shark runs in
3d a third tracks for shark were
sharktopus if there's anything the
movies teach us it's don't go in the
water especially if you're a child
character no one's gonna miss or
attractive but if waters not your thing
anyways you might want to take a classic
family camping trip it's a splendid time
for bonding over a campfire and hanging
out with friends like John Kelly David
and Jason a guy so angry about his death
he had to kill 30 years worth of
teenagers to get over it if Jason's on
the loose you're gonna want to find
shelter just make sure it's not a cabin
especially if you're attractive of
course you can always run from the
danger but that gets tricky when you're
camping spot or ups and lava no matter
what you do don't go on a medieval
camping trip or else you'll confront
lots of walking but if nature is not
your thing there's always theme parks
the ultimate vacation for thrill seekers
of all ages they usually tell you all
the safety stuff before you get on the
rides but just a refresher keep your
hands in the vehicle at all times don't
flash the light in the Dinos eyes stay
away from the zombie clowns don't trust
roller coasters and I can't help you
with that one don't do drugs I guess of
course you can always stop by that big
adult theme park Las Vegas a citywide
sleepless playground where you can win
thousands of minutes and spend thousands
and seconds
but beware the dangers of alcohol as it
can cause you to steal Tigers tattoo
your face adopt the baby and think that
shooting the hangover part three is a
good idea but aside from all this
there's plenty of safe summer vacations
right how about Africa no Europe nope
stay home no cruise ship no hiking
definitely not hot no Hawaii that one
might work out okay at the end of the
day you can get done in no matter where
you are so might as well be on vacation
when it happens but to be as safe as
possible make sure to travel in groups
be aware of your surroundings and don't
be attractive thanks for watching and be
sure to check out more vacation
disasters on fandango movie clips
you
Oh
Oh